Well think of it.
This is the way we thought about it.
Where is the most defamation rooted in
our society?
Still?
What,
what aspects of society is there still a
lot of homophobia,
um,
against,
uh,
against the lgbt community?
And you look at the world of sports and
we have a long way to go.
And so we created the sports media
program to spark,
start working with media professionals
that cover the sports world.
When incidents come up that where
there's either been an active defamation
or there's an opportunity to educate
people through sports media,
we want to have that kind of influenced
the same way we have the influence and
the entertainment world and television
shows and films and so forth.
So the sports media program is working
without athletes on the college level.
Um,
some closeted athletes on the
professional level still and really
creating the opportunity to begin some
of those dialogues.
And then we're also talking to a
professional broadcast journalists,
people who are sports casters,
people who are writing stories about the
sports world to see if we can have more
fair,
accurate and inclusive representation of
lgbt athletes.
Whether they're on whatever level
they're in,
but certainly there's a lot of young
athletes who want to be able to compete.
Um,
maybe someday as professionals,
certainly maybe in the Olympics and they
want to know if they can be out.
He's like,
it's a great story.
We got an email not long ago from a
mother who is saying,
I'm,
my son is an amazing high school
athlete.
Um,
he's out and I want him to be able to go
to a college or university where he can
be out as an athlete and be safe.
Where should he go?
You know,
where can,
where can he look too?
This is his sport.
This is what he wants to do.
This is coming from a parent,
which is just tremendous.
So we shared some information with that
person,
connected them with some people at some
universities that are very supportive of
the lgbt community.
And someday we'll be able to tell that
that young person's story,
when he's very successful as an athlete.